this colonial pipeline thing you know um
you know everybody's getting hit by rats
somewhere probably one of the first
times that's actually
realistically happened to a mass
population is there anything the company
can do about that
other than just not having stupid people
the biden administration you know are
they gonna do anything about this
this is where i do actually side with
our friends over in the far east
why don't we build you know a secure
network and by the way responsibility
includes if you don't get your house in
order and your [ __ ] together
you come in with me and you can spend
the next couple years staring at
concrete walls
end of discussion
welcome back to generally speaking we
have chris roberts back he's going to
talk to us about the colonial pipeline
attack we're going to talk about
the florida almost water poisoning we're
going to talk about the memphis bombing
and a whole lot more
we're going to get into what the what
the country is or is not going to do
about it so i'm looking forward to the
conversation i think you're going to
love it too so chris welcome back
and it's great to have you back yeah
absolute pleasure and honor to be back
on again so definitely
so so chris this colonial pipeline thing
you know
um you know everybody's getting hit by
ransomware but
when it affects uh you at the gas
pump that's really when people start
to take notice you know i was looking at
these people that were lining up
and as as some of these stations ran out
of gas in north carolina
so can you walk people through you know
your
um your sense of how that was pulled off
and you know what what kind of company
like can colonial do about it
what should they do about and more
importantly what can the government do
about it and
are they going to do anything about it
yeah absolutely
um yeah that was a good one because
it really made people sit up and think
and i think it's
probably one of the first times that's
actually realistically happened
to a mass population in more than just a
couple of places
so again standard standard operating
brief as an attacker
as an adversary i'm gonna look at you
and i'm gonna go okay how can i get into
you can i get you to click something can
i send in an
email can i get you to go to a website
which is pretty much so what happened
so very easy very normal way of an
attacker an adversary being able to
break into something
we see it unfortunately almost every
single minute of the day we're across
the globe
then what ended up happening is the
attackers turned around and said okay
we can make some money out of this you
know we're in a very vulnerable
environment we're in a network
that has plenty of computers plenty of
systems plenty of infrastructure
that we can start to encrypt and that we
can start to basically take advantage of
so they were able to
in the physical world they were able to
get into somebody's house pretty easily
because the door wasn't really locked
very well
so they'll kind of nudge against the
door and i'm in and then when i'm in no
alarms are going off silent or otherwise
nobody's coming to chase me nobody's
running at me with weaponry
let me have a rummage around and see
what i can find so as an attacker you
start rummaging around you're like
there's some kind of good stuff here
let's see how we can take advantage of
this
and so they started to you know encrypt
computers now the differences on this
one
is the encrypted system and they put
systems offline
that obviously control you know some of
the most
critical east coast pipeline systems
that we have today
because again if we use the house
analogy
when the house is maybe connected to
your car garage
which is maybe also connected to a few
other things
and i can move easily just by opening
another door going hey look at this oh
there's some cool classic cars here here
let's grab those
and you know you go through that and you
go into the the storage shed and you
realize the storage sheds got a whole
bunch of antique like john wayne stuff
and then you're like
hey quit bring up the truck let's grab
all of that stuff too
and so if using the physical energy they
were just able to move from room to room
to room and just
basically take whatever they wanted or
in this case encrypt everything that
they wanted
and at that point you go from because
both the com
the regular computer networks that we
all think about the office computer
networks
were in a in a position to be able to
affect
the pipeline networks so if you think
about it a pipeline isn't just carrying
you know oil and gas and everything
it has sensors to measure the flow to
measure the pressure to measure
temperature
to measure how effective and you know
you every now and again you'll see them
they're amazing screens they've got the
shapes of the pipelines on them and
across all of them
there's all these controllers years ago
those controllers were
completely separated from a regular
corporate computer network there was
just no way of accessing the two of them
and then some bright spark said but we
don't we don't want so many people out
in the field we'll kind of get rid of
them we'll pension them off
and we'll plug the two networks together
and it'll be fine
well as we know obviously it isn't fine
because we didn't put any controls in
place to restrict the connectivity
between the two
and then also what's happened is i'll
come along and i'll sell you some new
sensors for the network
and you'll plug them in and because i
don't want to have to go into the field
and look at the damn things
i'm going to say to you hey in order for
me to sell you these sensors
i need to be able to access them and
you're like all right
and you give me access to them and it's
basically a direct connection straight
into the sensor network
unfortunately a lot of times bypassing
any security controls that might or
might not be in place
so it's basically like giving me the
keys to where you store your you know
1950s and 1960s and 70s high boys and
saying that's fine just go in and check
them and you know don't worry about it
and i give enough of these sets of keys
out and of course now i'm trusting
all of my third parties i'm trusting my
suppliers and my vendors
you know as well as i do that sometimes
the easiest way to take somebody out is
not go through the front door
it's to take them out through their
friends their family their colleagues
and everybody else it's the same thing
i'm not going to maybe necessarily kick
the front door of the company down
i'm going to look to see if their
weakest points are their transportation
or their vendors or supply chain in this
case they just kick the front door down
but
yeah sometimes you might get it right
well the uh
when i was uh when i first started
working on this u.s china thing i
remember reading the briefing where
the guy who was a football fan um he got
sent a newsletter
and inside that newsletter was uh was a
link
uh that ended up being just like what
you talked about and so
a lot of this um is social engineering
or human engineering
if you will so the vulner the big
vulnerability that you're saying
that occurred here in colonial was not
so much the the system as
it was the people that are in within the
system and now is there anything the
company can
can other than telling the people stop
clicking link which i know
we get all this you know in the military
you get computer-based training which
you know i i just absolutely hated um
and it's like don't click the links like
what idiots clicking links you know
actually when i was in
when i was in the pentagon the joint
joint staff got hacked by the russians
for the same exact reason
and then and then we all had to go to a
room and they say
don't click the leaks i'm like come on
guys
but we send out a link on the calendar
so you can click the link to go to the
meeting that says
don't click the link right but then
there's a seal
on the email and you know yeah yeah
you know yeah preaching to the choir
here right but i mean is there anything
the company can do about that other than
just not having stupid people i guess i
i there's a ton we can do
i mean that's that i think again is
where the frustration is
there's so much we could have and should
do
first and foremost we can educate the
people you know and you're right the
problem is if i come up to you
i i know the training you probably went
through once a year
or maybe once a quarter if they were
advantaged they run you through the same
training
that they ran you through last year and
you already know what the answers are
because you remember them from the year
before the last year when you did the
stupid things
so we do the same exactly i'm done okay
now great another cup of coffee
so we do the same stuff and we do it
once a year and let's face it we're
humans we we remember things for what 10
15 20 30 minutes if we're lucky so once
a year i tell you don't click it don't
send it don't do stuff you shouldn't do
that's going to last maybe until
lunchtime maybe till the end of the day
we also don't engage i'm not going to
look at you and go hey
let me help you protect not just
yourself and the organization you're
with
but let me help you protect your kids or
the family and the friends around you
parents grandparents whatever let me
help you protect those
and here's how so that's one we educate
the humans way more effectively
it's also a lot cheaper to do that
secondly the very computers we use
there are so many things that we can
do yeah you know what everybody's going
to click something great so now i can
put something on the computer that says
hey
for the last month general you know you
you've done these things but hang on
you're now starting to do things
at two o'clock in the morning or your
computer is starting to ask
questions of the rest of the network
your computer is starting to talk
to china i'm not sure i really want it
doing that
let's have a quiet conversation about it
so there's so many things we can do
and there's all that info we just
we just don't always do it or we don't
why why then why wouldn't a colonial who
you know is absolutely reliant on the
fact that it pipe
it's pipeline why wouldn't they do that
because it takes time
it takes effort and it's it this is the
stuff where you literally have to roll
the sleeves up
crack the fingers and get the basic
simple stuff done
it's much easier to get wooed by
somebody who comes in and goes oh
take care of all this thing and
basically don't look behind the green
but don't look behind the green curtain
in the security industry there are
simple things that a lot of us
can and should do and unfortunately they
tend to get ignored and we tend to
forget to simplify and do the easy stuff
and we tend to focus on you know hey
let's put something
the vendor told me it was artificial
intelligence or as quantum entanglement
computing and it'll solve all my
problems and it's 100
effective we tend to get wooed by all of
that and we tend to ignore the very
simple stuff and it's
it takes time it takes time and it takes
resources it takes it takes work to do
this
the um so you know the the
maybe the company didn't want to spend
the money maybe didn't want to take the
time
um you know obviously corporate
executives still
aren't being held account to these uh
for these types of things happening
um you know what what could the
government do you know if if the cut
the company's not going to do anything i
want my damn gas
what can the government do but so what
ca
and so this actually this is where i
do actually side with our friends over
in the far east
this is this is the one time i'm
actually gonna side with them
i told you to fix your problem i even
gave you the opportunity i gave you the
resources i gave you the compliance
framework nist 853 sb
if you continue to be a complete numpty
and you can do i'm pulling a truck up
i'm going to knock on your board of
director's door and you're all
coming with me end of discussion
no trial no collect 200 no
bye bye we're gonna go have a
conversation you might be back you might
not be
don't wait up for us that's one of the
few times i actually agree with those
guys
because what we do nowadays we're like
well you know you really shouldn't do
that
bad people you know we'll find you a
couple of million um
and then that gets passed on to the
consumer unfortunately so that's what
annoys me we've seen it in retail we've
seen it in healthcare
bad person you shouldn't have lost those
80 million records we're going to find
you 10 million
what happens our flip and insurance
premiums go up yeah how effective is
that one
what we need to do honestly is look at
the entire board of directors and go
look first and foremost we're going to
educate you
as to what you have to understand from a
risk standpoint
so that's on the cso let's face it it's
on the cso and the cto chief information
security officer chief technology
officer
it's on us to better inform and better
communicate to the board of directors
it's on the board of directors and those
people that are obviously in charge
let's face it
[ __ ] should roll up hill so you know
this as a general you are
you are responsible for people for
humans for lives and everything else
you are held accountable for those
actions
in the civilian world unfortunately [ __ ]
kind of rolls downhill
i don't want it i literally somebody
needs to walk up to the ceo's office
knock on the door and say
i'm holding you responsible for the very
simple fact that you've failed
and by the way responsibility includes
if you don't get your house in order and
your [ __ ] together
you come in with me and you can spend
the next couple of years staring at
concrete walls
end of discussion so you're you're
you're a big uh you're
you're a hard ass on when it comes to
this but you know what
we need to i mean no i i agree with you
but
logically that's not gonna happen so
what so
you know the biden administration you
know are they gonna do anything about
this i mean
you you were talking before the before
the start of that that you thought that
they might so
what do you think that they might do or
uh or do you think this is just
they're blowing smoke so they they
literally ironically enough
in the conversation they literally just
put out a directive which which has said
to
critical infrastructure and i think
they've just done it for pipeline
which says that you know you now have
and it's
hours it's like 12 hours to notify us
and this is like the u.s cert things i
think to notify us of a breach
well great but
how are you going to handle it how are
you going to deal with it what are you
going to do about it are you
so are we now going to be on the hook
from the government standpoint are we
now going to be on the hook for
deploying a team out because again
you can't take care of your own apps you
can't keep your own house in order
does that literally mean we have to
babysit you
probably yes for the minute but so
there's
there's definitely more of the we're
removing the voluntary breach because
what it used to be
is what would happen is if you got
breached you'd get the boardroom
together you get senior leadership and
you'd bring the lawyers in
and you and then you'd have a
conversation as to well did we get
breached or was it just
something that happened did anything get
lost yes or no can we prove that it got
lost
do we have to tell anybody and so
that's why don't you don't you think
that that's probably going to be the
first thing that happens even with this
12-hour
you know the lawyer is going to come in
there and say don't don't say anything
they don't have any
they don't have the authority or
jurisdiction
you know is this going to be one of
those another one of those executive
orders like trump had he had
i think he had like 75 000 executive
orders and
uh the court nullified 75 000 of them
so you know as unconstitutional or
whatever i don't know
but do you think that's what's going to
happen here
so so yes they said they make it look
like they're doing something but then
the attorneys are going to come and say
well they don't really have
jurisdiction here i i got a feeling
there's going to be fight back on it no
two ways about it because there's
exactly to your point it's like well
hang on i got to notify within 12 hours
the flip side is is also within seven
days and i think that seven days of of
whenever this goes into effect
is they have to notify basically tsa dhs
and some other folks cisa
about what they do have in place so
which means
they've just notified the market which
means it
impacts the stock which means yeah uh
they all get fired yeah so so but so
basically you just told
your your c suite that um my my new
executive
order is you tell me so you can be fired
that's gonna
that's that's not gonna work um and
that's so
yeah yeah it's just it's it's a hard
problem the um
the the other thing that really happened
you know since i talked to you last was
the memphis bombing
in um in
att's data center and it took down
it took down firstnet it took down 18t
and some other networks for two or three
days in that area and
not just in tennessee but other
surrounding states as well
in fact you had cell towers that were
within range of each other that couldn't
talk to each other because your core was
down
so um so
you know what what are we doing about um
you know
we have a highly kind of uh hub and
spoke
centralized data center type
infrastructure today
you know even a tier three data center
has redundant you know
uh fiber redundant power but if it goes
offline
it's offline and there's only a few of
them so
you know what you know what are we doing
about that what do you think we can do
about that or should
do about that so it's it's it's um
we've seen similar attacks not at the
physical level but at the digital level
the dns types attacks and then there's
been a ton of attacks on what we call
the call routers
so how the internet traffic moves across
there have been some massive attacks in
the last six twelve months
where you're talking i mean we always
talk about denial of service type
attacks where somebody just
floods a network pipe to try to bring
service down
we keep seeing more and more of those
and they keep getting i mean they're
massive attacks
now the thing we can do you know as well
as i do
is it all comes down to delivery it all
comes down to your supply chain is how
can i make my supply chain more
redundant more resilient
if i lose this data center what are the
consequences and knock-on effects of
losing this well
can i have a secondary data center where
i can do replication well i can but
there's a cost with that
so we can and so the best way of looking
at this is
and we've had long conversations about
this behind the scenes
when you look at computer servers we
always talk about what's known as raid
configuration so redundancy
configuration
and we see it in encryption we see it in
all sorts of other things
and it's if i have a piece of
information
how many times do i have to split bits
of that up to then
worst case scenario if i split it up
into five pieces
i lose two those three that are left can
rebuild my information
there's a company out of the uk actually
it's out of scotland that's actually
building a really interesting like
distributed rate architecture totally
cool guys
um and they can lose three data centers
out of seven and you can still rebuild
the information so i think that's what's
going to actually happen
is we're going to take that hulk on
we're seeing it you'll take the whole
concept of a hard drive raid
we've moved it to server and cloud raid
and now we're going to move it to like
physical location type of rate so
i'll take my one piece of important data
and i'll spread it geographically
disperse it
if i lose the east coast and midwest
well i can still pick it up from
mountain west and you know florida
or texas i'll just put a couple of we'll
just put it all in texas i mean they've
just removed all the armaments laws
we're pretty safe down there now
but but even if you've got a raid
configuration
and you've got a you've got a uh you've
got some kind of
um you know malware in there
yeah that can that's that's propagating
across your
your platform what is the uh what is the
way to prevent
you know to have you know say you do say
it is malware that locks up it's like
let's go back to colonial and say they
have
they have redundant systems what's what
is the kind of the best practices of
making sure that
if you do get something like ransomware
and you want to quickly kind of
go over to the next system but you want
to make sure that that ransomware wasn't
in that old system kind of what is the
best practice today about
making sure that you've got a backup
that's not as corrupted as your
primary you hit this word exactly and i
was actually reaching for it
is is what you do is is you take one of
these wonderful things called a hard
drive or a tape unit and you take it out
and you just put it off to the side
it's that complete ability to have an
offline
recovery capability and i think we've
forgotten that you know we used to have
that we all knew tape drives you only
you had that capability
we didn't put complete separation
segmentation between our active system
and our
oh [ __ ] system when you think about it
um you know i always remember
once every couple of days you know the
truck would turn up i'd hand them drives
they'd hand me the other ones to use and
off we go worst case scenario
if i can't recover from my raid
architecture
i can go back two days pull my backups
and i'm back up online i mean
i basically strip i completely strip
everything off the computer systems or i
bring in bare metal whatever so i gotta
do it
rebuild it and i'm done so
so basically you have some kind of air
gap between um
whatever you're going to use to restore
uh
restore operation and um and where
you know in the current system that's
that's that's corrupted
i i'd want i mean yeah we we have a long
conversation about air gaps and stuff
like that i literally i want it offline
i want the darn thing turned off
yeah and i want it yeah i i want a human
i want sneak in there i want a human to
have to walk to pick it up and get
moving on it
got it so um so the other one that that
recently happened i don't know if you
remember was the uh
in florida they some guy's sitting there
you know drinking his coffee
and he start
he he uh his he doesn't but his his
machine starts adding lie
to the to the water supply um
what you know what happened there and
and
so is this the same same thing as
colonial
no well yes and no
um colonial had some challenges that
they were aware of that they didn't fix
unfortunately in this case this was
this was convenience over security
and i think that's probably the best way
of putting it this was i need to access
your computer
instead of me having to go through a vpn
and having to go through these things
hey do me a favor can you just open up a
remote software for me
i'll get in it'll be fine and so we do
that a couple of times and then well
hang on i need to get in once a week why
don't you just leave it open for me i'll
get in when i need to
and that's great except you know as well
as i do any kind of remote software
that's directly connected to the
internet
is like a shining beacon in the darkness
for anybody who's an adversary
and unfortunately they're all pretty
darn easy to break into
and in this case our intrepid uh
water treatment plant left teamview open
and and
on the internet and somebody came in
very enterprisingly and
decided to help them out well so
you know this stuff is
i mean it's actually pretty easy uh you
know
yeah this is yeah and it's not like it's
it's rocket science it's
it's um you you wonder
um you know one of the things one of my
um
assertions when i was in the white house
was why don't we build
you know a secure network and we
basically have that for the military we
run all our scada systems through that
we run all our
you know critical stuff like you know
our telecommunications networks are
our electrical grid scada systems our
water supply systems
we just have a you know for lack of a
better word industrial internet for the
united states
um you know that uh what do you think
about that idea i mean
we're we're getting ready to spend
hundreds of billions of dollars
in building infrastructure uh if if this
administration can be believed
why wouldn't we go about um building a
network to protect
you know the water thing you protect the
the uh
you know att's data center to protect
the colonial pipeline and any other
thing that we find critical for
you know to survive we need to do we
have to do
we've got to do something different that
we're doing now no two ways about it um
my and this is where it gets interesting
you you we all know
from from the military.gov days the net
nipperneck architectures and
and the challenges on getting to them
and some of the other ones
and so i like that concept now the only
challenge on anything like that one is
if let's take colonial perfect example
if you draw a box around colonial and
say look we've got you covered
we will come in with our own networks
our infrastructure our own systems
we then have to educate colonials to go
hey the vendor and supplier
you know emerson with us little boxes
they can't come in
we're not allowing them to come into
your into here into there
we have to give them access so we've got
to be much better
at how we gatekeep it we've got to be
much better at how we manage it
control it enforce it i mean we can do
it the controls are there
this isn't again it's your point this
isn't rocket science this is actually
pretty easy stuff to do
we just have to build it and effectively
put the policies and controls around it
so that we can manage it and just keep a
bloody eye on the damn thing
i mean that's it it's not that hard to
do
yeah and it seems like it's something
that we should do
i'm gonna throw a curve i'm gonna throw
a curveball at you here so
um in uh la early last year
uh imperial college of london put out a
report that said two million
americans were going to die because of
the coronavirus
now who do you think took a trip to
imperial college of london back in 2015
our friend xi jinping
oh interesting so so so we've been
talking about hacking
systems yeah um what
what have you done any work
and have you done any thinking on uh
hacking of mines because
you know what i what i say uh the
coronavirus was
uh wasn't a bio attack it was a it was a
information operation and it was very
much
related to uh can further control
strengthening control over the supply
chain
shutting down economies around the world
and essentially
doing so by creating mass hysteria or
fear
i don't know if you remember at the same
time that that report came out
we started seeing all these videos from
china people
you know walking around and just
collapsing um
and then now you go back and look at the
videos well you know the the person
catches themselves as they're collapsing
so it's not a
you know it's not a true collapse it's
kind of a fake collapse
uh so all those are going out at the
same time their reports going out you
have all the social media retweeting the
report
gets picked up by legacy media all of a
sudden fauci says we don't need a mass
we need a mass we need two masks
uh we need vaccination need to vaccinate
kids you know it's gone
um it's really you know fauci's doesn't
really have any
credibility uh remaining because he's
changed his position so many times
but if you know looking at what the
chinese have done
i think it's it's really and this is in
the area of
of of hacking but it's not hacking
systems it's it's kind of a
more sophisticated way of the of the
football football analogy that i said
where
you know they got them the hat to click
on a link in this case we got
we got people to be afraid and then we
got we got policy makers to basically
implement civil liberty destroying
policies uh that were based on that fear
what so what's your
what's your have you done any work on
that and what's your thoughts
so i've i've actually yeah this is where
it gets really interesting because
i've done over the years i've done a
bunch of work on
uh nanotechnology and bio nanotech now
we're not at the point where we can
influence through those systems not by
long stretch we're getting there
but we're not there yet not by a long
way but
to your point if you look at where we're
heading and you look at the information
control it's really interesting to see
and social media been a perfect example
and a perfect use of that
that social media really is the new
weapon i mean it's it's
both amazing and scary at the same time
to see how effective that can be perfect
example as you said
the toilet paper thing i mean good grief
it's
a toilet paper i've got boxes and boxes
of toilet paper now
but we have i'm like oh i asked my wife
like why are you buying all this toilet
paper but we have people shooting each
other corona 2.0
yeah over toilet paper well it's a
toilet i mean i'm like good grief
and that was out of a social
media post that was just expanded and
everything else
so you take that you take that one
instance to your point you also take the
corona side of it
we have so much information
disinformation misinformation floating
around
that one of the biggest challenges and
we're going to continue to see this
is what the heck is
the truth and you've got 300 about 350
360 330 million americans over here
how do we help them to actually
understand what truth is
how do we understand because i mean you
just saw uh current administration said
hey we need to reopen the conversation
around what actually happened over
there and facebook basically said hey
we're no longer going to censor the fact
that this make
may have escaped from the wuhan lab i
mean so they're basically
basically admitting that they were
censoring the what could be the truth
right and that's what gets to your point
right yeah
but that's it information i mean we know
that information is warfare but now
the difference is from a military
standpoint
we used to be really good at managing
that because we
could we could very easily influence we
used to drop leaflets years ago then we
go around with megaphones
you know we had the ghost squadron that
did its job in the second world war and
subsequently and then we had the
obviously the agencies do their
counterintuition i mean
we manage that well the problem is now
it's in the hands of everybody
so now you get to a point where okay
what
is reality and and who's managing that
reality these days who's controlling
who's dealing with it
who's influencing it you know wuhan
being a perfect example we're reopening
it so now
everybody's bubbling up all of their
theories well
how do we understand what's an actual
what's a theory
what's somebody just brainstorming and
what's somebody who's trying to
influence us is
the russians trying to bring stuff and
is it china who's
who's trying to influence us and why
well and then you have to take into
account you know the chinese strategy
of essentially becoming the saudi arabia
of data
so they can use it to power their ai
you know one of the things i've thought
about is how do you
how do you prevent people's information
let's collect about them
from the you know the metadata that
comes off their smartphone
now you're starting to build cameras
around cities so you're tracking people
you get in one of these scooters they
know where you where you're
going where you've been all this data is
being collected about you and it's
available to the highest bidder
and then you know silicon valley
companies are basically taking that data
and trying to figure out how to
make you buy more stuff yep that's
that's not
just like you said going through one
door into the garage into the kitchen
if you if you can influence economic
behavior now social and political
behavior uh come
right in there you know another one
that's that
that uh you know i have some a little
bit of insider information about is
you know some of these voting machines
they say that they're not connected to
the internet
when when you tear them down there's an
lte modem
inside and uh and technically
uh you can't get to the internet from
the modem because it's actually going
through a vpn to a server
but isn't that the same as being in
colonials um system
yeah oh by far in a way so the voting
systems
so the voting systems is an interesting
one i would argue this
is where quite honestly i would take my
little black truck that i'd borrowed
from our friends abroad and and
drop it around to three companies and
i'll be nice enough not to name them on
here unless you want me to
but there are three companies that in
this country that i would drop that
black truck round to and there'll be
some really really awkward questions
the voting stuff i'd argue we've done
that to ourselves yeah
we have been terrible at allowing those
companies to go
everything's fine leave us alone we've
been absolutely awful
at holding them accountable we've been
really bad honestly protecting the local
and states because if i don't want your
voting machine i actually want to use
something that is more secure is more
effective
and has had a bunch of hairy hackers
break into it
i go to have that conversation now you
feel slighted and come charging after me
and going well you shouldn't be allowed
to do that and you bring lawsuits
um huge amount of problems with those
things that i mean the list of issues on
voting machines is longer than my arm
that's my biggest impact but but we're
saying there's no problem there
that's the thing that's that's crazy and
that's that's so we have with the voting
systems we
at least we have the human eye
as that secondary factor yeah to do the
best that they can to count now here's
the problem
because we haven't fixed the darn
machines
that opens up all sorts of questions
that don't get answered properly
and let's face it we're humans we make
mistakes so you've got a mistake written
system
being unfortunately monitored by humans
which make mistakes
so you've opened yourself up for more
questions
more points more fingers pointed than
you
ever needed to do if you'd just taken
the time to hold those companies
accountable yeah there's so much there's
so much going on
um the the last one i'm gonna really i'm
gonna and i'm gonna stretch you a little
bit here boeing
737 max
isn't that a [ __ ] show with wings so so
so you're you're you're the ceo of
boeing
uh and and somebody somebody
you know how do you deal with something
like that i mean
uh not the way they dealt with it let's
put it that way you don't wait for
two planes to go down hundreds of people
to die before you go
oops we might have made a mistake and
then
and then kind of like uh like solarwinds
did they blame the intern so
you know what what boeing did is they
they blame the design and the engine
again [ __ ] should roll up hill to your
point that ceo should have done a mere
calper and gone
we made a mistake engineering should
have never allowed it to go it shouldn't
have done it we shouldn't have used
software to try to compensate for an
engineering floor
and then when it didn't work we blame
the pilots i mean absolute that's
another one where my little black
truck's going to roll up and there's
going to be awkward conversations yeah
you're going to have to have a little a
lot of little black trucks because
you know we've just covered you know
multiple major industries in the united
states
and um and this is not just confined to
the united states it's basically
going global and so you know
you're king for a day you're you're
you're president for a day or maybe
i'll i'll make you president for eight
years um how do you clean this up
what's your recommendation what are some
what are some things that we could
you know that the government could do
that should have been done a long time
ago
because look um i look i trained my
entire career to drop bombs six thousand
miles away from this country
yeah we're not we're not protecting the
american people that way
no it's it's it i just talked about you
know
many different things that directly
impact the survival of
lives and had nothing to do with uh
with warfare and the way that i was
trained to do it has more to do
uh in in kind of the way that you're in
your world so you you're
you're present for eight years uh how do
you fix this mess
first and foremost accountability you
know that from the military world it's
accountability
so when you come up to me and i'm a
computer security vendor and i turn
around to you and say it's 100
effective and it turns out not to be no
accountability we have no accountability
in our infrastructure we have none
in in most of the stuff so the
accountability is going to be done
probably quite a number of lawyers will
probably end up in those little black
vans
so that would be fine is this this
require legislation you think or
i mean it sounds like you know we need
some kind of new legislation not just an
executive order that can be overturned
in in eight years
exactly this this needs to be
somewhere this needs to be written on a
piece of flipping rock to be perfectly
honest
um yeah accountability is huge
that to me is probably one of the
biggest and one of the first things that
needs to happen
um then we've got in this country
300 plus million vulnerable people let's
actually help them to help themselves
that means a huge part of it
how do i help you to help yourself how
do i how do i teach you to fish rather
than keep giving you stuff how do i
teach you to fish more effectively you
know we've got
we're all running around with these
things we've all been given these things
we've been told that these things are
amazing and they're wonderful and
they're great yet guess what you know
and i've done this example a few times
this
we all think of this as being lethal we
all think of this
being terrible this i can kill more
people with this yeah
that's right that's right so i mean to
your point i mean
why why hasn't this been implemented in
our education system why are we teaching
uh uh digital hygiene or cyber security
uh
in our education system that's a great
point so i think that's that's one of
the things you're talking about right is
just
yeah having it because nobody ever you
know if you go get a gun
you have to go through uh safety
training right in order to to get a
concealed carry permit or go
get a hunting license you have to
actually have physical training
on the weapon so what you're saying is
hey we're not going to give
these kids smartphones uh they're we're
going to give them training first and
they're going to have to demonstrate
some
acumen and then before we hand it out to
them is that kind of the the idea
that that'll be a huge part of it
because again you talk about all of our
data being out there
it's because we continue to hand it over
we don't ask the extra question one or
two extra questions
i hand you it what are you going to do
with it how are you going to take
how are you going to look after me oh
you're not hmm now i'm going to hold you
accountable
so that now i've gotten the data and
accountability side of it sorted out
now we're going to work on the
protection the knowledge the information
so you train more people we work
we did it in the military we brought
people into the military we trained them
we gave them a trade
we gave them a life we gave them a
career and we did the same thing
when they left we at least enabled them
and gave them the capability
we do the same thing in the security
industry that is the new domain let's be
perfectly honest
so how do we bring apprenticeship things
through
effectively how do we tell companies
stop
chasing the unicorn when you have an
opening a job opening
don't go chasing somebody with 10 years
experience a cissp in 25 certs
go get somebody that just stepped out of
a bloody uniform
take some of the government money
retrain the heck out of them and then
you got somebody loyal for the next
goodness knows how long we need
that pipeline needs to be way more
effective
um yeah and then the last
the last uh um discussion i had was with
somebody that um
had a lot of experience in the nuclear
um
industry or nuclear enterprise uh in the
in the department of defense
you know i think the other thing we need
to do is we need to harden our
infrastructure you know one well-placed
emp
over uh the top of the united states
from say north korea
the lights go out you know uh i don't
know do you remember what happened
uh when uh when katrina happened i mean
it was like it was
they they actually they flew c-17s to
iraq they redeployed the
the the louisiana national guard who was
in combat
in iraq yeah they flew them back to
to new orleans and um and i remember
they
interviewed the guys like what do you
what's it like and he says i i
doesn't seem like i've left i i'm in the
same kind of environment that i left in
combat in iraq and so
and that was just after you know within
a few hours
uh new orleans was a was a war zone and
so think about that
one well-placed emp over the united
states and
and uh and lights out and how what's the
implications for our society i mean use
your phone for everything
you can't get money you can't pay for
your food you can't you know
i think what will be interesting is will
be the power shift because i mean you
think about
north dakota south dakota kansas
nebraska
a lot of those folks now had to cope
without one of these things
right right all of a sudden you have the
folks in nebraska going all right now we
have a little bit more control
that i would love to see this is like
that you're it's like that song a
country boy can't survive he's right
yeah there we go well chris
yeah this has been a great conversation
it's uh
you know i love to do it again um you
know we'll have to
you know every six months kind of
revisit and see
how how the world's gone wrong in
between um
great conversation i really appreciate
you coming on general speaking and
uh look forward to the next next one
honor
thank you so much appreciated
[Music]